[Music]
so we focused attention on some of the
behaviors on the very dark side of the
spectrum of hopefulness and optimism
which is suicidal behaviors and we dug
into that literature we saw the
importance of suicide as a cause of
death for young people and for teenagers
it's the number two cause of death for I
think ages 15 to 19 in the United States
and the a lot of the scholarship that's
focused on suicide has focused on
individual risk factors both genetics
and the presence of physical and
emotional pain and what we wanted to do
is think a little bit broader about
social contagion and social processes
related to suicide in processes of
social contagion and suicide have been
also been under study because social
contagion and social processes for
adolescents suicide often comes up in
the news when a celebrity commits
suicide and there and there are there
are public policies for the media not to
report celebrity suicides in order to
not have spikes of adolescents commit
suicide as copycatting and more recently
the media is being trained and if there
is a celebrity suicide to report the
story but also report hotlines and
information for adolescents who are
feeling the same way so there's a lot of
public policy interest in the potential
for contagion and suicide so we focus
some attention on that in our study too
so what we did was we again survey data
that had information on suicide and to
think about social processes we found
data that had not just your own suicidal
attempts or suicidality but also whether
or not family members had recently
committed suicide and our thinking was
in order to trace a social process we
wanted to see in some sense patient zero
which would be a family member having
committed suicide and then traced that
through an adolescent social network so
we measured family suicides that
occurred in the previous year we examine
the impacts on the adolescents in the
families that had family suicides but
then we pivoted and asked the question
well do those family processes spill
over into the classroom so we examined
the impact of having a class
eight who had a family member commit
suicide in the last year and again we
found very large defects that seemed to
work through having a classmate's family
member commit suicide affecting the
classmate him or herself that then
spills over into the classroom on the
suicidal behaviors of those who are not
directly affected and the other
surprising finding in that study was
that these pathways between a family
member committing suicide and adolescent
increasing their suicidality and then
spilling over into the classroom is that
that process only follows gender lines
meaning that it's if I'm oh if I'm a
female student in the classroom it only
matters to me whether females in my
classroom had family members who have
committed suicide the males in my
classroom who had family members commit
suicide does not affect my suicidality
so there's a very I think intriguing and
surprising finding it says something
both on the potential for spill overs
for contagion in suicide but also that
it's a little bit more complicated
because once it moves into the classroom
I think these suicide contagions take
advantage of pre-existing networks where
girls are friends with girls and boys
are friends with boys inside classrooms
and when a bad thing happens to a
classmate's family then that seat that
that news and those effects seem to
travel on gender specific lines and
similar to the child abuse examination
where we found that family member or
family processes spilled into the
classroom there's a policy implication
here that's that successful suicide
prevention programs again have this
potential for spilling over on people
who aren't treated themselves or who
aren't intervene on themselves if you
can successfully prevent a suicide in
our case in a family member that
actually reduces the likelihood of a
suicide attempt in both the adolescent
in the family but also the adolescents
classmates so again we this has the
possibility of a larger bang for your
buck where you spend money to reduce
suicide or spend money to prevent
suicide in a single family that's but
you gain the benefits of both the family
and the classmates of the family
[Music]